all right let's see what's uh Katie's
got for us here Katie how you doing
talk to moth on stereo okay a lot
um and I told him that I would listen
today and so I was in sitting here and
uh he said you should call in and ask a
question so here I am
um uh I've decided to ask
um our biggest point of contention
usually is can men and women be friends
with each other
can men and women be friends yes I
suppose you can but I don't recommend it
um why do you ask the question like
what's behind it
so well it's something here like it's
something often I talk have talked about
several times and it's like our biggest
point of contention the it's the one
thing we'll probably never agree on
um so
uh
she says men and women cannot be friends
I think men women can be friends
um
why wouldn't you recommend it
well the problem is is that men and
women don't have a lot of common ground
when it comes to interest like I'm not
interested in the stuff that women are
interested in
and women only become interested in the
stuff that I'm interested in if I'm
dating them right
um so there's that element the other
problem too is is
um if you're hot I'm going to want to
bang you
right like like there's there's no way
around that I mean any guy that you're
friends with that you're not sleeping
with that you just see as a friend I
guarantee you he's had thoughts in his
mind about banging
Okay so
like you just have to understand that
and that's why if um I have a girlfriend
that has guy friends or she wants to be
my girlfriend and she gives me the talk
like where do we stand you know I dig
your Vibe rich I want to be with you I
don't want I don't want to be with
anybody at blah blah blah sort of thing
one of the first things that I would
look at is okay well does this chick
have any guy friends and if she has guy
friends you know I would simply just say
look you know
um I'm you know like I dig your Vibe and
I'm happy to invite you to my life but I
don't date women that have guy friends
right so that's just a simple boundary
that I set because it's like look
it if you're going to get into a
relationship with a a chick as a guy you
don't want dudes hanging around her
which are obviously going to be trying
to bang her you know if you're hot sort
of thing so it's as simple as that
so my okay I have a follow-up question
okay why does the fact that
the man like why does him wanting to
bang me
automatically like make us not really
friends
well I don't want to bang them off
right well okay like I'll hang out with
moth we'll have drinks we'll do dinner
you know we shoot the [ __ ] sort of thing
but I have zero interest whatsoever in
wanting to bang them sort of thing the
only reason why guys generally want to
be friends with a woman is because they
think that they can friend zone their
way into your pants
at some point they're just hoping you
know one night when you get drunk enough
stoned enough hanging out enough long
enough you're just gonna be like Oh
Billy is really such a nice guy so I
want him in Me Now sort of thing that's
that's basically what they're thinking
um
okay
I know it's I know it's hard no no you
know like it's a difficult pill to
swallow and it's difficult for women to
grasp but that's that's literally the
entire Dynamic the entire problem oh no
I'm fine with that I um I I have spent
several so many hours talking to Mom so
I've gotten that
um but
I just don't so I guess what like what I
don't understand is even yes I can
actually like really absolutely agree
with what you just said like I cannot
think of a man that I'm friends with
that wouldn't like
sleep with me if I called him right now
and asked him yeah I have to prove it
like I could like one of the tests that
I tell guys to do is if a chick just
says oh well he's just a friend then I
would say okay cool pass me your phone
and I'm going to text him right now I'm
horny let's bang I guarantee you he's
gonna accept right yeah
um but like why does that mean that he
doesn't also like just
enjoy my company or like uh have similar
interests to me or whatever it is you
know whatever you do how do you define
friendship I guess
look um a brother and sister might have
that kind of relationship but again if
you're an attractive woman and he's a
healthy male
he might pretend to be interested in
your story about Becky from HR and the
[ __ ] she did last week with Billy
and all the stuff that went down but in
the back of the mind you know he's
thinking okay if I hang around long
enough she'll probably yield and you
know we'll get it on sort of thing like
like that's the ultimate goal that's
what he's trying to do but yes you know
you can play house you know you can play
the game of of friends but men and women
really aren't that great at being
friends you know there's there's there's
people to be like oh we're just platonic
friends and all that sort of stuff but
no it women can be friends with guys but
guys can't be friends with women because
they want to bang them you know it's as
simple as that
that's why from your perspective you're
like I don't understand why I just can't
be friends with a guy but you can women
can literally want to sit with a guy and
tell him or her life story about Chad
and why he's not calling her back and
blah blah blah sort of thing and the
whole time he's thinking to himself at
some point we just lost her at some
point
um you know she's going to lower her
defenses and want to come back in right
like that's you know that's essentially
what the dude's thinking I don't know if
you heard the whole thing if I lost you
there no thank you no I just um I hit
the button on my headphones and it
kicked me out does that make sense
yeah that makes sense yeah uh
you know you didn't trust him off so you
wanted to check in with me no he just
said ask him anything you asked me and
that was the first thing that came to
mind because that's like our biggest are
we aligned like are we saying the same
thing basically yeah I know you um you
basically yeah
okay cool did you have any other
questions
I think we lost your audio
um yeah did you have another question
yeah
um not tonight but I will likely be back
with more yeah anytime you want
awesome thank you all right hey guys I
really hope that you enjoyed that short
clip if you did consider supporting the
creation of content by checking out my
supplement line pinned in the top
comment below of this video in the
comments there's a link to the
unpluggedalpha.com forward slash shop
when you click through you'll be able to
land over here and the entire lineup is
broken down by category that it performs
best in estrogen metabolism fat burning
your foundational Essentials for health
immune Health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code Alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the Subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching I
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out